la société a été construite de manière à
garder les gens endormis pour les garder endettés
pour les manger un sentiment d'
impuissance à nier ce qui est juste
devant les cuisses qui sont ce qui étaient des esclaves
parce que nous allons créer un appel le matin
ce n'était pas tellement des théories du complot
eux-mêmes car c'étaient les gens qui y
croyaient qui m'attiraient nous avons de
jolis arcs les théories du complot sont
plus répandues dans notre société aujourd'hui
qu'elles ne l'ont jamais été Terrence et des gars comme
lui s'ils se trompent et c'est vraiment
fou ils pourraient être si  délirant est le
gars que vous baignez le monde 911 rencontre avec la
CIA ceci ou pas les
gens ne disparaissent pas disons
qu'il y a ces gens qui
dirigent secrètement les choses alors ils ont toujours
dirigé les choses à travers l'histoire mec
j'ai essayé de conquérir le  monde d'
Alexandre le Grand Napoléon le
Hitler si quelqu'un pense que cette fois nous
ne l'avons pas fait est différent je lui ai demandé
lequel d'entre nous est vraiment fou